let's kick it off with the bay club
getting a little debate club here with a
young fella have you seen the show
before mark you know what you're dealing
with just clips I like the honesty at
least fresh what up guys got a little
bit of debate club for you inside a home
you shoot the six pointer or a bud take
a slap shot Canada versus Mexico who's a
better neighbor gang gang butt plugs
Canadians are so nice they don't do much
for us but they're so nice they got the
hottest chicks up north go to Toronto
get a Montreal gonna Vancouver Ottawa
Winnipeg is gaining a ton of the fame
that would be a good name game name
places in Canada they get CFL which
actually hurts them they should fight
think they should fight here on American
soil
Canadians yeah like why can't you
haven't been on fight island have ten
representatives from each make it a ten
on ten like an Olympic type of thing
yeah I guess things are definitely nicer
and there's no cartel up there a lot of
Hells Angels but they're not gonna [ __ ]
with you next thing you know we're about
the cartel they have more resources than
anyone they [ __ ] it up her up yeah great
food though they're kind of like
Hayden's got maple syrup salsa from
Mexico he's just talking about uh yeah
Mexico's like the whole kind of the
off-white Africa a little bit dangerous
no the wrong part super famous oh yeah
safaris summer the zoo the guy tried to
almost get it soon they had fires and
we're gonna do it yeah and then the fire
started then we passed $3,400 you don't
have a zoo basically we have Joe exotics
before it happened yeah and then there
yeah literally a week later everybody
involved in the deal was burned to the
ground
so you're definitely more barbecues down
in Mexico I feel like they call the
Irish two Mexicans a Europe why can't
you just do like all the work
Catholic and just fun chances pikeys was
stealing it will sell it here and they
do a lot of asphalt over there what else
do you guys do today Paul I never do
actually yeah roofing gypsies are
hilarious thought they literally put an
ad in the newspaper for a car and if you
want to buy it there go and steal it and
then sell it it takes about seven eight
days to Pena
one time my uncle saw ad in the
newspaper and he was in the window it
was his car and he's in the wind or
doing the dishes and he formed the
police and the police were like yeah you
don't want any part of that family so
much fun the Wild West
yeah I'm trying to think Oh God Mexican
girls are not my wife is Mexican my kids
are not Mexican yeah boxers he's not
going Mexican yeah
I'm telling you Brock come up to 235 and
meet you dog if I was fighting but
that's enough get you on them supplement
yeah I've to got off the middle ones got
real juice get that you have to call up
your boy I would be gargling
testosterone
dude that's a tough and Wow debate club
who's the better neighbor oh that was
the question I thought it was who win in
a fight you're go back to fighting
Canada is a pretty friendly neighbor
Canada is definitely the better neighbor
there's definitely more Canadian
listeners yeah I don't know our market
in Mexico I think we have a lot of
Mexican American listeners for sure
but do they consider themselves Mexican
or American I guess it's I don't know
man you can be both yeah yeah so I would
say I'd say let them fight I think I
mean eight sometimes they do I mean
America to see a Canadian fight Oh
Mexican all the time America runs on
Mexicans a true you know yes
undeniably yes like it's better for the
most part jeeps what stuff um ma'am
what do you think Kat I'm gonna have to
say Mexico I grew up in San Jose with
nothing but agents and Mexicans so I
can't go
Canadian Wow and do Asians and Mexicans
get along with each other we either
don't get along and it's terrible
or we're the best of friends it's one or
these no middle ground there's really no
middle ground like I grew up in like I
was cool with all the Mexicans I grew up
with but chin had a terrible experience
at Texas not just Texas when I moved
here I lived in Santa Ana my parents are
still in Santa Ana and Santa Ana is
straight up that's like Mexican Ville
cholo heaven yeah Wow
and then they were mean to you can very
mean this cuz you were a giant Korean in
their City probably probably a fat
chubby Korean here were 300 pounds yeah
now is that their fault no reason to
beat me up but yeah that's no reason to
beat him up myself
they will beat you up and see yourself
cuz you're a big fat maybes Asian Wow
skateboards bikes fishing equipment to
be fair you told me that Vietnamese
people did that to you too so I don't
know if it's necessarily like maybe I'm
just agent
maybe I skin the trouble or no maybe
it's you maybe it's me I mean not to say
that but it's like common denominator
thank you bro maybe they you know thank
God for them like kind of like a agent
Doug funnie a little bit
what's Doug fun huh he doesn't know yeah
Doug funnie what was the owner Nick
alone Ian he's like a drawing man
cartoon on he had his own TV show it was
a cartoon he did Oh Doug oh yeah he's
come Doug don't you drop his last name
Doug that's a good car yeah my eyes are
one kind of BD so I don't see that man
to get beautiful eyes thank you mmm that
was actually
beautiful eyes Oh Doug was big here that
was good Doug why do people a lot of
people hated on it huh people some
people call him a wig or two I remember
was it was he like real shy and super
friendly yes and there's Patti how does
a real [ __ ] right she always liked [ __ ]
tease on him all the time
I think she was she might have been
Dutch or something that's the whole crew
there click on the whole squad his
brother was green remember that threw me
off
there's his blue friend old a bully pork
chop was the dog
yeah pork chop had a I liked him why I
was good a great cartoon in Ireland do
you guys do you have different who's
y'all's arch-nemesis wouldn't like
woodland yeah all the time
you guys still think you have the best
you guys are stealing a bag certainly
one car at a time yeah you can see why
they don't you are you a big whiskey guy
like Jameson yes he is do you know what
I
I drink whiskey but when we do show they
drink whiskey yeah I come here and
people got me into Guinness and whiskey
because they're like do a whiskey shot
you're Irish and eventually I'm like ah
race it already care yeah but like I'll
drink a drink if someone hands it to me
oh yeah do you feel like you're letting
your people back yeah when I was
drinking too much Skinner's looks
getting chubby
oh yeah yeah lose the way you don't get
a bicycle to join the fake boy bike club
yeah you know any for that kids have
getting hit by cars on bicycles ahead of
time losing weight they might break
their jolly candy either way they're
losing weight what about the guys who
kill the fat kids they're all full
circle dude but should they be in jail
which question we never answered your
question what was it what was the
question a few
I went out drinking we both agreed to
get in the car whether you're driving
around driving and you crash right crash
and one of us dies yeah should you go to
prison for murder if I'm conscious now
here's f of here's the point is if I'm
conscious and I make the choice because
then I'm really saying if I'm conscious
enough to know you know we've been doing
both drinking right we've been buying
each other shots all night
I'm almost saying hey I don't want to
take the risk you take it so part of me
is really that you know what I'm saying
I'm not really it's like yeah we're
gonna go this party you've been drinking
I've been drinking let's jump in this
ride right but but still it's like if
we're both safe we're both wasted right
and we know we both probably shouldn't
be driving then at that point if I say
all right man yeah you drive it's almost
like me kind of wimping out it's like me
song with you on this too if you've done
that before have you with your friends
I'm dead my frogs on it we're both drunk
my buddy's like hey I'll Drive us and
I'm like [ __ ] we both need to get there
but the point is we both agreed to get
in the vehicle right knowing we're both
under the influence yeah you know you
have to take some responsibility for it
agree I got no matter what happened
right we should both take responsibility
for it well isn't the responsibility
that one of you guys died we mean in
this thing that was the risk we both
don't because we could have both died
yeah so happen for whatever reason I
didn't hit the tree Theo did or vice
versa
and we both took that risk he just got
the [ __ ] end of the stick and also and
all fun and also I don't think it was
upon what your tattoo artist also hit a
tree you hit a tree but what I don't
know I'm saying is and I'm kind of like
in it it's it's not even like against
what you're saying I'm just saying like
say if we're going to get in a car and I
say hey man yeah if I'm like thinking in
my head oh cool I don't want to drive I
don't want to risk me getting a DUI or
something I'm gonna let my buddy dry
then it's almost like me say it's like
but you know the risk okay a great point
it's almost like you know I'm agreeing
with you I almost know where more it's
almost like I'm I'm like you know the
repercussions like dude if you pull over
you know do you I go into jail right and
your buddies at buddy's like hey who
should drive it I'm like if in my head
I'm doing the math I'm like well [ __ ]
you
all right now yeah we got one strike I'm
already dressed like I'm going to jail
yeah you know I'm already dressed like
I'm going to prison at Eddie Bauer
you're a dress like Andre actus he's
gonna be a punk that's actually true
twos that means you're Morris Oliver
it really is it so it's a weird
it's a [ __ ] argument I stood up my
brother when we were drinking we were
young we were bored hammered like 14
gonna say four didn't you guys and I was
like uh I got a time I less you go home
first and he'd be drunk walking on my
mom's like you're drunk again and I walk
in I'd be like I can't take I can
imagine
showed up to your funeral to on his bike
and he's just like I could have been me
semi blown to hurt you know when you get
enough DUIs they used to force your car
to have those things where you blow into
it when I was a kid I was a help alone
this is fun for me would have been a
hell of a lot of trauma 255 blue
high-calorie 36 gram sure you can drive
but it gives you directions not to pass
any bakeries on the way wouldn't it be
crazy in the future of cars if whenever
you blow into the breathalyzer it like
knows how you what you need like
physically and stuff for vitamins
everything and it takes you on a path
that keeps you out of the out of like
cool any fast food or anything don't
they kind of fridges like that like your
fridge knows when you're running low on
stuff yeah those orders directly
yeah I won't put Mexicans man if you I'm
saying Mexicans that thing you know yeah
I want to go with Mexicans I like cannon
more than Mexico my wife is Mexican my
kids are making but I'm drawn to the
Canadians man I love it's fun of so
friendly because great Jeff ELLs up
there yeah the grass is always greener
huh it's always greener on the other
side Wayne Gretzky's Canadian the grass
but the grass ain't getting mowed bro if
you don't go Mexico that's kind of a
cheap joke it's a tough call man
it's a tough call are there any Mexican
Canadian people that's gotta be rare I'm
sure but I'll be twenty too many
there's a lot of Native Americans in
Canada yeah sir oh yeah yeah a lot of
them ran up to Canada when everybody was
killing them down here a lot of them
were from there though yeah cuz it used
to be all just one big place you know
you shouldn't be a bunch of Indian
people Indian or Native Americans
running around like aw [ __ ] we're lost
you know yeah Kevin Canada has a lot of
Hell's Angels its depends how you look
at I won't say it's a problem but the
other Hells Angels up there like one of
the biggest chapters is up there I mean
I will say loud mufflers are a problem
so I'm gonna go with yes huge nothing
ruins homework right Chan like a [ __ ]
muffler some loud we're going by which
must be a problem in you guys community
that's insane that in the asian
community you guys do homework and also
drive the loudest muffler VX which makes
it so hard to [ __ ] focus on anything
pressure makes diamonds that's why we do
so well
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]